[Musique]
salomon touche pas à mon panneau partie
préparer c'est pour nous c'est qu'à l'om
deux malades
je rappelle ses 35 heures 1000 euros
pour l'association c'est que du bonheur
pour chaque heure de records
je vous conseille aussi de voir après
c'est que du bonheur une émission de
défi est là il va se passer un truc
énorme aussi entre cyril et mathieu
mathieu ne le sait pas encore mais
manquez pas ça ça fera un petit peu tard
mais ça vaut le coup d'attendre avant de
nous occuper d'ayem qui est en panique
depuis c'est sa médaille à un grand jeu
un grand je ne savais pas qu'on fasse on
faisait des jeux comme ça ici mais on
les fait donc plus de 20000 euros de
cadeaux à gagner
avec une question très difficile pour
participer envoyez baba par sms au 73
838 ou appeler le 39 27 la question
c'est qui présente les quatre tiers dont
les pmp
réponse un thierry moreau réponse de
jean luc lemoine élevé les séjours ski
surtout des magnifiques week-end allait
alors on va avec les casinos partouche
aux multiples un de choses dans
l'oreillette arrêter les mecs là
j'entends des abayas de beit lahya des
bêtes ça vous n'êtes pas peureuse est ce
qu'on peut faire rentrer le le cobaye
pour ayem ou est ce que tout le monde
s'en fout 12 mois comprend chevaux
attention étrangères le schéma est ce
que vous avez déjà touchée une chèvre
non mais là j'entends des bruits venez
venez veille m alors qu'il savait très
simple ouais vous devez toucher l'être
humain qui sera en face de vous et
devinez ce que c'est qui c'est pour le
coup vous le touchez les poils les poils
ouais ok
j'aime ça c'est un mec déjà qu en mode
beau gosse un peu il prend soin de lui
l'ami du gel parce que vous reconnaissez
un petit peu seul en scène moderne on y
comme ça là sans odeur à loder qui ça
pourrait être
je touche et les baskets 6 et des
hadiths à souder stan smith et martial
c'est sur la toile
ailleurs
c
gagner la place de mathieu au ps c'est
bon parce que visible via une chef je ne
sais pas ce qui est fait sur le plateau
alors merci alors est ce que vous avez
lu ayem depuis début de semaine non non
je demandais si marcel vous avez vu
depuis le début de la semaine
j'ai regardé langue dit oui et est ce
que vous avez entendu ce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure sur qui présentait mieux
way est ce que ça vous inspire
quelque chose vous voulez réagir à ça
déjà moi j'ai vu effectivement le débat
dans le dans le cagibi là où vous m'avez
mis pour me pour me cacher donc la
surprise pour la surprise oui mais j'ai
vu les boîtes de chat tout ça c'est très
sympa ici mois déjà première chose
tout va bien déjà il ya un débat tout va
bien j'ai pris un choc évidemment lundi
c'est normal mais tout va bien j'ai dit
j'ai acheté un trampoline pour rebondir
donc rassurez vous déjà et deuxièmement
je trouve ça assez cohérent écoutez moi
moi sur cette chaîne j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup donné donc
j'ai pas trop compris pourquoi ça s'est
passé ainsi
à tel point que j'ai refusé tpm tes
moyens la semaine de l'année dernière
pour vous rejoindre
ce que j'étais vraiment pieds et poings
liés avec mon directeur ça s'est fait
comme ça c'est la loi de la télé moi je
suis là ici pour pour montrer qu'il ya
pas de polémique a pas de petites
phrases ya de la place pour tout le
monde c'est le principal et de toute
manière quoi qu'il arrive je perdrais
contre cette dame donc voilà des choses
à rajouter sinon passez par cas s'il n'y
a pas de souci pas d'amertume moi j'ai
toujours reconnu ses talents il le sait
j'ai pas d'amertume là dessus tout à
l'heure capucine elle en a parlé on a pu
avoir nos différends je pense que tous
les gens qui pensent bosse ensemble au
quotidien ils ont tous leurs différends
ça a été le cas on a deux caractères
très fort on à régler nos comptes
quand on avait un truc à dire on n'y a
pas d'amertume il le sait il fait
toujours partie de la chaire il sera
toujours le bienvenu et franchement il
n'ya aucune compet est en tout cas moi
y'a aucune amertume de mon côté blonde
limited d'identité alors avoir peu léger
retrait avec la dark alors on l'a vu dès
lors il ya notre ami le mexicain qui est
là qui depuis le début de l'émission là
je suis une sucette donc la dar k qui va
devoir lécher la sucette du mexicain
vous inscrivez le nom que vous voulez
sur votre ardoise valérie gillou gillou
ayem capucine non gilles c'est à dire
que là c'est tout le sens où c'est dont
géraldine hockey gilles gens me jean me
gilles verdez a je crois qu'il ya un
vieux contentieux martial et gilles
gilles suis désolé je crois que t'as
qu'à de vote contre toi c'est toi qui
vas les chaînes mexicain
et tout à fait bien ça arrive une fois
dans une vie sain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quand il fait ça en me regardant
dans les yeux ça m'excite presque et là
tu regrettes un petit peu quand même
c'est dégueulasse allez on va faire une
vérité pour finir n'avaient été pour la
regarde qui va devoir nous dire quelques
chroniqueurs crash le plus sur le dos
des autres
la valeur à temps ma vision est
quelqu'un qui veulent dire les deux
demandes à capuche et a bien compris le
jeu voilà on va désigner la personne qui
va devoir balancer sur les autres
valérie jean michel c'est jean-michel
isa iam et opus in cape une 11e et
soprano je vous confie t il
valérie journée d'essai chez moi j'ai
pas de crème et je m
jamie jean-mi alors jean mi ces gens me
qui doit désigner celui qui tire plus
drôle c'est dommage que ça tombe sur lui
parce que alors jean-michel d'après toi
ma personne
le bonhomme le bonhomme la saison mais
le mec qui sort tout cela gêne toujours
avec respect avec sympathie mais c'est
vrai que j'arrive au tournant avec
costumes rêve avec quoi etc respect oui
ok on verra ça demain on était petit
rappel c'est tout ce que tu avais à dire
bah oui mais moi ça me fait marrer mais
je sais jamais méchant sa part et
méchante j'aime bien peut provoquer
ouais elle adore tous franchement même
quand ils allègent la chari franchement
je les adore j'ai passé le week-end
dernier avec elle était adorable sa
maman aussi son maïs franchement je t'ai
que sa maman aussi franchement gênant je
passe en ce que tu as fait que sa maman
a les temps d'accueil à camille combal
pour le poste de surveillance
à léon jean luc comment ça va bien très
bien alors le patron est sur la route
ouais on voit il est un pas il est dans
l'écran oui c'est ça je pense qu'on a
peut-être un duplex un peu comme pour
les soirées c'est beaucoup texto je ne
cache pas il est vachement sur son père
patron mais qu'il est beau quand il
téléphone
non je pense qu'il va me couper le son 5
e pour les amis quelques petites choses
que je vous ai ramené quand même ce soir
un petit peu de questions pour un
champion et un coup d'oeil sur la
voyance mais on commence comme chaque
soir par le pendant ce temps là ce
toutes les images que vous avez
peut-être raté depuis le début de
l'émission ce pas m 3 la séance de
rattrapage il a pendant ce temps là sur
un thème pas et n'aura passé les
questions pour la première saison de
weeds how are you un majeur
eynaud c'est bien le petit et d'eau et
asus mais pendant ce temps sur mtv on a
vu que mokhtar s'est mis au rap en
espagne john moore clarté et enfin
pendant ce temps gérard louvin nous
donne des nouvelles il est déjà dans les
prépas
il ya toujours une oreille après bien
sûr il n'a pas pu c'est un vrai zicos
fabrique aux sujets caisse il a fait
combal depuis trois jours qu'il arrive
alors regarder la télé web on sait aussi
qu'il est le dos au laser m'enfin c'est
intéressant match de rugby clermont
toulon je peux regarder comme le rugby
oui oui arrive le mec se rebiffe
complètement biarritz évidemment et là
le match c'était quoi c'était toulon qui
jouait et way est un joueur était sur le
banc alors je crois qu'il avait froid ou
alors c'est qu'il était vraiment hyper
content de voir ses copains jouer face à
lui c'est l'un ou l'autre
quoi qu'il était exclu dix minutes ou
qui est contente volontiers les
marseillais donc hormis un petit coup du
lapin en commerces vendant les juristes
pas s'être quoique jour non trion rio
mais l'expression de l'année c'est une
candidate de un dîner presque parfait
qui nous la donne est enfreinte à un
premier temps encore ce qu'on a fait
c'est encore une fois l'hôpital qui
soudain je crois pas mieux la non la
trappe à travers la belgique ensemble le
matin mon jean luc tu te cgd rituel
chanter du laurent voulzy en
sous-vêtements et regarder motus s'aimer
de trucs cv de patios et cette semaine
un couple participe à l'émission c'est
un couple ils sont dus aux les deux
aient autant madame en mots de cette
lettre elle est assez calé au temps
j'irais pas faire un loto avec elle en
chat noir 2000
[Musique]
labo noir
les bons et du coup monsieur était un
petit peu vénère en super parti lui a pu
laisser en place et n'étaient pas des
seconds secondes3 et à 2,0 et crj
valérie verhée es forfait forêt faillite
et mais on adore ce monsieur si ta vie
toutes ses phrases avec un bruit le
petit chat vraisemblable smb l abbé eux
souriante et soeria nte
à rennes avant on change complètement de
registre je vous emmène avec moi dans
mon univers ce j'ai regardé enquête
exclusive sur m6 et dans la dernière
enquête
il suivait un policier policiers
français qui est parti faire carrière en
thaïlande voilà c'était son rêve
mais vu le niveau d'anglais tu sens
qu'il est quand même plus des landes en
aquitaine que tu as you do you stop me
thomas kremser nous manquer mais
question au gouvernement sur france 3
manuel valls était clairement venu pour
chiner de la députée aujourd'hui est
honteux parce que nonce les droits de
nos concitoyens
tous conseils de reconnaît
ce que vous proposez et enfin exclu pose
de surveillance bernard de la
villardière à des montées de lait ça
arrive été facile non mais pitié otobre
août que francophones
de piste à l'autre crétins qui
m'envoient et sage sur son ardoise fait
tu gères tu es beau jean luc richer sauf
à quelle faille aux yeux c'est pour
demain il a peur oui la peur mais la
raison d'avoir peur en plus pas de bien
ça et katia oui demain dans dans des
dans le prime avec ça voilà alors moi
j'étais sur m6 vous avez suivi à l'eau
se réveille un peu valoches j'étais sur
m6 je suis resté bloqué à qu'il est doué
il est super merci jean n'y ait dans
l'âme et leur boulangerie de france il y
avait un couple sur le point de
s'embrasser ils veulent ce gars là
dessus parce qu'ils sont tous les deux
mais y'a la caméra donc ils osent pas
vraiment regardé reste en étant donné la
baisse ses ambitions à steam et karine
lemarchand recevez regarder bruno le
maire et je fais pas pourquoi bruno le
maire à plein de photos de matthieu
delormeau chez lui explique pas mais la
vraie star de programmes s'était pas les
politiques mais le chat de karine le
marchand qui a connu pas mal de galères
les enfants comics avait créé et 10 du
luc et photographes
issu notamment sur lui que j'ai
surveillé toute la télé quand je dis
tout la télé je peux même dire idf1
boulot et sur idf1 les vendredis soirs
je sais pas si vous savez il ya des
grandes soirées voyance voilà ils
reçoivent des voyants qui parle pendant
des heures des heures et ce vendredi
c'est quelqu'un qui était tout à l'heure
à l'antenne avec nous qu'on aime
beaucoup
c'est claude alexis faux taxi il est
hyper bon pour tout ce qui est voyance
prédictions et tout en rien problème
c'est qu'ils apprennent de téléphone
donc il a dû mal entendre les
téléspectateurs y arrive plus à lire
dans les as mash up et de la 3g galère
un peu plus friable
non j'ai pas compris
oui comment mannum malo man on man show
mais comment umar dont ils commenceront
à quitter oui oui comment oui un petit
peu
il faut comme en mai vendredi dernier il
y avait surtout france bulgarie au stade
de france et pas de bol les studios
d'idées afin qu'on situe à deux pas du
stade
du coup tu entends les supporters du
stade hurlé tu pouvais suivre le match
en direct devant la voyance quoi il faut
de galérer
mais y'a quelqu'un quand même qui
ressort à côté de vous bien ce serait
bien d'avoir un amour de jeunesse
également un déplacement en voyage à
l'étranger aussi pour vous
[Musique]
à l'entrée du stade on entend le statut
lesquelles j'ai été voir un voyant une
révélation étonnante valoches oui
valérie moi oui non mais n'a pas tout
dit non non moi non bah oui qu'est ce
que tu as dit capucine quoi ah on m'a
dit non je suis allé voir une voyante et
on m'a dit après justement mon départ de
nrj 12 parce que j'ai eu peur pour mon
avenir on m'a dit que j'allais bien
rebondir et la preuve en est la moins
bon j'aurais dû bon résultat une voyage
suite ou des jets d'eau vous êtes plutôt
friand de ce genre de choses
beaucoup de voiliers en moins heureux et
ma vie est guidée par les voyant on est
bien en phase
je n'en vois régulièrement et ont
vraiment eu de nombreux éléments toi
indiqué les trucs importants
oui mais quoi par exemple les grandes
destinées sentimentales les grandes
histoires avec des prévenus que fatou
vous l'avait annoncé avant évidemment
d'ailleurs vous a dit que finalement
elle accepterait de mariage un moment ou
un autre ou que ça va être difficile il
fallait s'obstiner on m'a dit que
c'était une histoire qui allait durer
etc
je crois beaucoup à toutes ces choses là
va bien péter l'ambiance
[Rires]
alors j'ai aussi surveiller aujourd'hui
question pour à questions pour un
l'émission ou quand tu perds tu repars
avec une encyclopédie et quand tu gagnes
tu repars avec une encyclopédie nom et
dans l'émission d'hier samuel etienne a
posé une question pas simple les
candidats ont proposé 200 réponses
étaient interminables
quel nom apparaît pour le titre de ce
roman dans lequel françoise huit noms
dans laquelle tony hawk et 12 non plus
berne à cette non plus dans cette non
hervé jeu tiré le coup sinus de douze
noms ton pauvre jean françois le 14 73
non plus erwan non plus je dirais 473
non plus c'est pas ça va dommage car
thannois l'afjel samuel etienne
prends-moi coup de la route dans la
tronche jetons esclaves magois de
respect je suis une merde à face à face
photo cl et pékin nicolas verser des
milliards
je rappelle un album de soprano qui sera
en vente dès demain des dommages
si ben je suis un peu vous serez
également en concert
concert à paris à l'accord hôtel à
renault merci le 30 septembre 2017 il
faut déjà réservé et au nouveau stade
vélodrome ça c'est une consécration pour
nous à ces trucs dessus et ça ça sera le
7 octobre 2017 est en tournée en france
et mois prochain c'est l'un des poissons
dans le mag
les stars l'ont très bientôt
gomis et on vient nous rappeler tout de
suite syrie la série dès qu'ils doivent
faire c'est pour nous c'est cadeau
ensuite il ya plein de surprises tout
plein de choses à gagner c'est pour nous
c'est cadeau avec cyril hanouna retour
et 35 heures de barbares et n'oubliez
pas la télé c'est que là
[Applaudissements]
pour nous cette
ça va être la folie on s'en fout quoi
merci d'être avec nous
l'antenne
[Applaudissements]
ne pas se faire
on vient tracées des allées 7 heures sa
tendance
cette fille laurence pour la tentative
du bonheur au soir bonjour
et là pour danser
[Applaudissements]
poto poto poto pour l'événement et sur
ses 80 ans ce soir les chéris merci vous
êtes vous étiez venu pour danser mais
c'était quoi le top en fait il y avait
un top pour que vous dansiez c'était
quoi c'était quoi jeter mon arrivée mais
je suis arrivé depuis deux heures merci
en tout cas merci d'avoir été là merci
les gars c'est important ils sont 400 ce
soir dans le public on est en direct ça
va être la folie déchiré encore je vous
dis puisqu'il va y avoir dans un instant
c'est pour nous c'est cadeau puis y aura
une soirée de défis avec tous les
chroniqueurs qu'on dit et ce soir je
sais que vous aimez cette émission vous
êtes 400 dans le public
vous ne savez pas pourquoi vous êtes là
il y en a qui repartiront avec des
cadeaux
il y en a qui repartira de créer un
alors il ya eric ella il n'a pas
travaillé de la journée puisqu'il
n'était pas avec moi il va absolument
faire un peu dire tout le monde il y en
aura qui repartiront avec rien non ça
c'est pas vrai tout le monde repartira
avec quelque chose
car c'est la fête de l'eau
n'hésitez pas à réagir à ce tag les 35
heures de baba et sachez que pendant ce
record donc je voulais dire chaque heure
passée je donne 1000 euros à
l'association c'est que du bonheur et
vous allez voir qu'il y aura des grosses
surprises
vous êtes tous là pour quelque chose
puisque regardez vous êtes tous là vos
proches nous envoyer des vidéos vous
concernant parce que vous êtes tous des
personnes extraordinaires ou des
personnes voilà qu'ils avaient envie de
récompenser et bien ce soir on va
démarrer cette émission avec un premier
témoignage mais juste avant est ce que
matthieu delormeau est arrivé puisque
matthieu delormeau bien sûr et là il
fait partie de cette émission mathieu
delormeau qui va voir de gros défis à
relever
matthieu delormeau liquider la matthieu
delormeau merci matthieu delormeau ne
sera pas là ce soir merci pour lui merci
et bien pour le moment est ce qu'un
certain damien et dans le public un
damien damien damien dernière damien
sétois damien tu t'appelles damien bien
beaux jours
[Applaudissements]
lentement fédérer dominé
dicro les shérifs au micro mais
crocheter micro merci joseph comment ça
va bien ça va ça va bien tu t'appelles
donc damien damien c'est gagné merci et
là normalement le mec me dit je lui dis
tu habites où il me dit je viens damien
je suis derrière damien et là ça fait
une blague télévisuelle la boutade
exactement damien avec qui es tu venu
maman matam a manqué là elle est là elle
est donc là c'est maman mais oui elle
s'appelle comment gisèle gisèle gisèle
est ce qu'elle veut venir nous rejoindre
gisèle gisèle la maman de damien qu'avec
regardez
non non non valide
non
je sais
mozilla merci à alors on a des petits
moyens on n'a qu'un micro pondeuses donc
gisèle merci d'être là gisèle vous avez
vous avez combien d'enfants
combien d'enfants 8 8 enfants huit
garçons élevés car son ca est pas et
combien d'enfants 20 petits-enfants 20
petits-enfants
vous n'êtes pas quoi dans la vie d'un
bien je suis chauffeur livreur d'accord
donc vous chauffez vos livres et et ça
chauffe salive sache aussi habité ou
affrontement parisy près de roissy en
france et dans le val d'oise oui moi je
connais très bien car j'étais un petit
peu toute la région parisienne sachez
que une ville une meuf voilà préfère
vous le dire
damien nous envoyer une petite vidéo
regardez cette vidéo parce que damien
vous à piéger
gisèle regarde je me présente d'amiens
alors moi je fais cette vidéo ça sera
pour faire un beau cadeau à mes parents
mes parents qui ont eu huit enfants deux
garçons dont je suis le dernier
ça veut dire aussi huit belles soeurs et
21 petits-enfants donc une grande
famille tout ça est en fait ça fait un
petit moment qu'on cherche à se faire
des vacances tous ensemble mais c'est
pas facile de trouver pour 39 personnes
donc je te plaît baba si tu pouvais
faire quelque chose pour nous ce serait
vraiment super je te remercie musique
et oui ça nous fait donc ça nous fait
non vous voudriez partir en vacances
avec 30 personnes
oui quarante personnes j'ai pas le
budget
à trente je passe à 40 je bloque je
blogue j d'accord je bave n'ont donc
vous seriez vous seriez 30 à partir en
vacances tous ensemble vous n'avez
jamais fait de votre vie non forcément
ça coûte très cher c'est ça voilà bah je
sais quand il faut chauffer faut livrer
faut chauffer faut livrer un bon prix
moyen un moment on peut plus chanter un
peu plus libre et donc incessamment
damien c'est ça et bien gisèle j'ai une
très belle surprise pour je vais sortir
du plateau
regardez vous à venir avec moi j'admire
avec mambé n'est que moi je n'ai que moi
j'écoute mercredi belle connaître madame
venez avec moi on est en direct regarder
merci merci merci on est dans le noir 1
voilà merci c'est une très bonne idée
merci les chéris voilà alors je me suis
caché je sais pas où je suis je vous le
dis merci vous êtes sûr qu'il fallait
sortir par là merci même les gars ne
savent même pas où on va
voilà donc c'est ça on va où là est ce
qu'on peut savoir où on va merci on sort
venez on sort on sort on sort on sort on
sort on sort alors venez venez venez
avec moi blé on a perdu le cadreur venez
avec nous il pleut en plus il pleut
merci il venait à venez là venez avec
moi venaient tous avec moi venez la rive
on doit passer par là on doit passer par
là ok attention venez là venez avec moi
regardez bon marquerait qui aura une
voiture à gagner tout à l'heure dans ces
pour nous c'est cadeau mais pour le
moment
regardez la surprise qu'on vous a fait
dix années damien on doit marcher encore
combien de temps merci regardez bien il
y à issy
jijel et damien jalet damien est ce que
est ce que voulait est ce que vous les
reconnaissez
oui c'est toute la famille de gisèle et
damien qui cela nous explique yahia
gadiris acquise à tours-nord oui il ya
bien plus clair qui montre toute votre
vie
et bien vous allez pouvoir partir en
vacances tous ensemble mais je vais vous
expliquer ce qu'il voulait il doit
refaire vous vous êtes tous installés en
dominos humains
c'est très simple il va falloir faire
tomber tous les dominos dont tous les
dominos à chaque fois vous faites tomber
ou partent en vacances pour que tout le
monde parte il va falloir faire tomber
le dernier domino qui actionnera ici
même un bumper et il faudra faire sauter
mokhtar mokhtar et bien l'attacher nolan
the dark avant motards alors attention
si vous faites ça vous partirez les
cherry en vacances tous ensemble
d'accord je le dis alors attention vous
êtes les 39 membres de la famille
regarder ça va démarrer de là bas est-ce
que vous êtes prêts il faut faire sauter
mokhtar attention on part du domino là
bas est-ce que vous êtes prêts qu'ils
allaient ce que vous voulez donner le
top avec le micro tops
et hop
[Musique]
récit
nous sommes là
c'est vieux
[Applaudissements]
vous partez tous en vacances
et bravo à vos stars vous l
vous pensez avec toute votre famille
il arriva chez eux les données micro
sarah magie s'agit de tout accroc trois
mois j'ai tellement bon alors on va vous
dire ou presque aux chorégies oui par
qui vous plaît parce que merci les
chéris alors vous partez avec tout vos
fans vous partez avec toute votre
famille vous partez dans un château en
thalasso aux frais de la princesse avec
toute la famille c'est pour nous les
shérifs au parc
[Applaudissements]
la bouteille
éléments de la version les autres sites
populaires parce qu'ils en ont besoin
merci d'amiens
merci gisèle merci mais je n'ai pas trop
visible à la trappe et franchement merci
mais je continue parce qu'on a d'autres
choses à faire on a plein de jeux
akira qui on va faire plaisir c'est
parti merci le shérif venez avec nous on
continue l'émission est en direct bien
sûr danser pour nous c'est qu'à d'autres
[Musique]
ouais j'aime bien cette émission
on est en direct c'est pour nous c'est
cadeau gisèle qui part avec toute sa
famille ça vous êtes contents qu'ils
veulent et cadeaux je n'en ai pas pour
tout le monde malheureusement je n'en ai
pas pour tout le monde par contre j'ai
une personne que j'aimerais voir ce soir
il ya une autre personne en public qui
va avoir peut-être une très belle
surprise
est ce qu'il ya un pierre henry dans le
public pierre henri pierre henry ph il
ya un mec qui s'appelle pierre est
persuadé que c'est lui il manque juste
le henry vous êtes pierre-henri bien
arrivé venez voir microsoft
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah oui
au matin monsieur à la pierre henry et à
18 ans ouais ça va
j'aime bien la poupe là c'est pas mal ça
on va taper dessus avec mon frère qu'est
ce qui se bat on a tapé dessus avec mon
frère un peu raté quoi faire également
non pas du tout il a dit je suis un
étudiant étudiants quoi en
économie-gestion je vais prendre ton
micro parce que je te réponds pas dessus
j'ai en fait j'ai un peu surpris tu
croyais pas du tout que c'était pour toi
non c'est vrai que tu nous a envoyé une
vidéo ou pas moi non
non donc c'est normal que tu t'attendais
parce que je ramasse c'est peut-être
pour ça en fait on te dit que tu venais
pourquoi pas pour regarder ton émission
pour les 35 heures d'accord mais sinon
tu t'es venu comme ça tu m'aimes bien
sinon ouais beaucoup j'aimerais qu'on te
regarde tous les soirs de terrain il ya
trois mois je te fais un bisou mais des
mois par contre tu as une maman oui mais
elle s'appelle betty way betty betty
elle est la betty bettina où je la
connais bêtises parce que l
en revanche elles nous envoient des
vidéos et dans mon dos ou dans ton dos
vous êtes combien de frères et soeurs
bon j'ai deux frères
j'ai l'impression que tu doute un peu
mais c'est je suis surprise surtout il
s'appelle commenté deux frères cadets
temps est clément
gaëtan et clément et il ya maman c'est
betty maman et féconde ravis et
travaille dans un restaurant et fait la
plonge d'accord ça va beaucoup mieux je
sais que ma fille elle bosse beaucoup
bon on va regarder la vidéo de batterie
que tu te fais partie bonjour c'est
betty de bordeaux bègles la maman de
pierre henry et son rêve ce serait bien
évidemment d'avoir un ordinateur
portable mais moi ayant un tout petit
salaire je ne peux vraiment pas me payer
merci du fond de coeur
pour pierre henry pour moi même avant et
oui maman voudrait un ordinateur pour
pierre henry je vais demander à betty
venir nous voir des noirs mais qui
viendra
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'abord à l'état
merci betty merci d'être là alors avec
les trois garçons ils sont gentils ou
pas avec toi et ses amours c'est vrai
c'est des amants ils ont l'air lille à
lévis a l'air d'être un amour lui oui il
travaille bien à l'école mais il a
besoin d'un ordinateur mac ça coûte cher
je sais je sais que c'est pas facile
cette affaire d'ordinateurs même moi
j'ai baissé les bras je suis tâche la
plus encore la pub non mais je te le dis
j'en ai marre alors bon tu n'as besoin
d'un ordinateur donc maman nous a écrit
et meti tu vas pouvoir faire gagner un
ordinateur à ton fils pa oui tu as
confiance en toi patron si ma moi j'ai
confiance en toi
mais si c'est quoi tes passions dans la
vie et chats les chats et bien justement
on va pas du tout jouer avec ça je te le
dis on va pas du tout peut jouer avec ça
pas des bêtes
alors maintenant à chaque fois que les
gens me voient non on connaît on connaît
les missions non mais equal en mai sur
un an ils pensent que je travaille dans
un zoo non mais sans déconner mais y'a
quoi mais je veux pas de bêtes alors tu
as peur des serpents à tout ce qui
rentre alors à la peur de matthieu
delormeau vais le faire
[Applaudissements]
ah bon
il ya apparemment ce qui s'est un petit
peu en retard je profite d'être comme ça
c'est que cet accoutrement
bon on m'a dit je sais pas vous mais tu
vas venir faire un happening ah mais oui
c'est vous qui allez faire gagner la
voiture
ah c'est vrai oui vous allez être sur le
toit d'une voiture on va booster des
trucs ah non
[Applaudissements]
j'avais juste après non c'est pas ça n'a
peut-être ensuite bisous tôt que je veux
dire oui à tout ça mais en plus je te
raconte une anecdote drame aura brider
ces brefs à leur voiture tard alors ne
fait jamais ce geste là devant moi ça me
gêne pourquoi je repars pourquoi je suis
venu en taxi moto ouais ce conte il m'a
planté il m'a coincée le pied dans une
roue de voiture je crois pas j'ai une
choucroute comme maintenant monsieur
[Applaudissements]
m
on est en direct c'est les 35 heures de
salaire on enchaîne les laissons donc
lui même
même les conducteurs sûr que ça vous
passez rires donc il ya les pompiers
m'ont mis une espèce de de nommer serge
grah mon chéri banon mais j'ai peur que
de mal mon pied double de volume alors
et bas juste le bac je n'aurais pas pu
le prendre dans la gueule mais non mais
sans rire sans béton armé savater plus
vous avez un petit une petite beauté de
magnifiques oui enfin qui m'a bien que
la petite boutique magnifique qui m'a
coincé dans le truck lâchant plus rien
parce qu'ils mangent les d'une bombe
avait le pied c'est normal le son la
taille normale merci bon bah très bien
alors on vous retrouve dans un instant
voulait faire un petit bisou avec
beaucoup à betty allez dis que je vaux
viti voilà merci
mais voilà j'ai appris à l'aimer thierry
betty boboul un ordinateur pour votre
fils l'ordinateur je dis pas qu'ils
aient gagné mais l'ordinateur il est là
[Musique]
varela
et
[Applaudissements]
là c'est quoi gisèle vous pouvez gagner
l'ordinateur pour pierre henry et vous
allez rentrer dans cette can make way
betty excusez moi vous allez gagner
vous allez rentrer dans cette cabine
venait jésus est là s'appelle jésus
c'est son vrai nom oui et on hamm est
même les gags cravec noms des prénoms
bizarres vous le dit voilà c'est normal
ces séries c'est comme ça alors allez-y
faites rentrer betty souple et jésus
merci jésus voilà il a travaillé deux
ans avec moïse
[Applaudissements]
allez rentrer gisèle gisèle ne vous
inquiétez pas il n'y a pas de bêtes
gisèle c'est tonton hanouna qui te parle
ouais et betty c'est bon j'ai sept
heures d'antenne derrière moi je
m'appelle les gens comme je veux pedro
rentrer dans cette cabine
betty est ce que ça va ouais est ce que
vous êtes en confiance
non mais tu j'ai un problème j'ai
l'impression que vous ne le faites pas
confiance
bon quoi oui ils vont me fait pas
confiance si pourtant je vous aime et
meilleure vie mais aussi betty jésus ici
présents
on appelle également j'ai su ce
ce qui est un petit peu data va
actionner une soufflerie
il y a ce qu'on appelle des golden
ticket tu qu'ils vont virevolter autour
de vous il va falloir en attraper un
avec la bouche vous disposez d'une
minute pour en attraper un avec la
bouche
si vous en attraper avec la bouche on
fera gagner l'ordinateur à votre fils
est ce que vous êtes prête meti john et
ou si vous ratez sur la tête de ma mère
c'est moi qui rentre dans la cabine et
c'est moi qui essaient d'attraper si au
bout de 45 secondes vous ne le sentais
pas vous prenez le joker baba et je
rentrerai et je ferai ce qu'il ya à
faire
ok betty ouais créée sous ce geste
j'ai fait
la sauce on actionne la soufflerie et on
va faire partir le chronomètre une
minute pour gagner l'ordinateur
il est magnifique à regarder 1h veut
dire là tu peux y aller et je tapote oui
qu'est-ce qui se passe allez je vais sur
tender bamba drap un oliva 1 voilà il te
plaît beaucoup
il te plait eh ben ça ils peuvent
peut-être à toi sinon cet ordinateur
repartira et je l'offrirai bien entendu
à jean michel maire pour qu'il puisse
aller sur des sites coquins
voilà
dès que vous après tout on me dit prête
donc métier frais de jésus attention
trois deux un top
ouais
à l'aller c'est gagné
attendez attendez attendez
attendez
betty vous avez gagné l'ordinateur ouais
l'ordinateur c'est fait mais on est
dense et pour nous c'est cadeau c'est un
beau cadeau un ordinateur mais on a
envie d'offrir plus à votre fils parce
qu'on aime fort je vais demander à ce
qu'on tourne le plateau les chéris parce
qu'il ya une grosse surprise pour pierre
ans
[Applaudissements]
le scooter
le scooter pour pierre henry betty oui
vous allez avoir maintenant trente
secondes
ge est très forte en gueule l'étiquette
trente secondes pour avoir un golden
ticket avec le nez jette une vanne ça
c'est une épreuve que seul gilles verdez
de réussite
vous allez avoir trente secondes
betty je sais que betty et je dis pas ça
à faire pleurer dans les chaumières
c'est vrai que vous vous travaillez
beaucoup vous avez voilà vous pouvez pas
gâté pierre auriez tous vos fils est
vraiment ce soir vous avez vraiment
envie de vous faire plaisir
si au bout de quinze secondes vous
sentez que vous avez du mal je viens et
ma bouche peux vous dire qu'elle en a
attrapé des golden ticket un je vous le
dit voilà je sais que je suis revu notre
chienne actuellement en plein débat mais
je vous le dis le golden ticket de ça me
connaît et dieu sait que j'en ai fait
bouffer françois fillon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
betty vous allez donc avoir trente
secondes pour choper un deuxième golden
ticket tu pour que pierre-henri
repartent avec le scooter attention est
restée prudente signeront d'offres le
scooter sinon je prends le scooter je
pars avec et vient retrouver mon vieux
ok oui fais gaffe formation betty quand
vous êtes prête vous me dites pme tpe
est je n'aime pas ce qu'ils disent ce
n'est pas ce que j'ai demandé pprt en
hommage à motus bien ps e t e pas ce
petit là avec moi assure petit temps la
has a fait six heures imminente est je
peux craquer je peut te [ __ ] en l'air
attention hier ça fait six heures et
demie et eric 7h30 7h30 bravo les
calculs ça ne connaît et bravo les
attentions
betty la série 3-2 un peuple
mais
attey
atteinte inacceptable à pop up la tête
de bêtises
quand elle essayait d'attraper les
tickets non mais
et il vient ma chérie je vais essayer de
le faire je vais me donner 30 secondes
pour essayer d'attraper dit on merci
celle entier et espère que ce match
allait baisser mais je demande 30
secondes
attention je vais faire attention je
vais d'abord faire la tête à la betty
mety si j'y arrive pas je peux pas
donner scooter j'ai les règles strictes
j'ai des huissiers de justice qui
viennent chez moi tous les soirs je ne
peux pas faire non plus n'importe quoi
et que cette émission je sus tu peux
envoyer
les gars oui c'est à quel sujet
j'ai un trac je suis en plein d'appels
téléphoniques et slow wear venir
monsieur non mais c'est ça nous rappelle
en fait les cabines téléphoniques ce qui
est ce qu'il existe encore des cabines
téléphoniques dégâts frappé comme cette
localité les beckham
[Musique]
j'attends n'a pas de kinshasa s'il vous
plaît jésus est ce que j'ai triché ou
pas jazz au guichet un petit peu piégeux
j'ai triché
un petit peu alors coulé et si je mange
le ticket d'alcool et taco l'état bush
contre l'alors point ça n'était pas ma
bouche c'était la langue alors et si je
mange le ticket ce qu'on valide
on peut valider donc je vole tu veux que
je vous fatiguer ça me plairait bien
cette paire est bien oui mais là on
échange de je suis
c'est rudy
[Musique]
ce que j'aime surtout diabétiques
on m'a dit c'est bon on peut avoir du
boulot s'il vous plaît pour moi pour
achalander merci merci jésus alors
attendez-vous ce qu'il faut qu'ils
avalent faisait pas figure de l'autre
s'il vous plaît merci bar près bordel de
merde mais excusez moi à l'eau ils ont
été la chercher ou à la fontaine de
trevi ouais c'est quand même un monde sa
mais si la bouteille d'eau
allez entamer à l'entamé les salles il
ya beaucoup de gens ça non plus
[Applaudissements]
m
vous repartez avec ordinateur et le
faire les séries
[Applaudissements]
là où des fesses des écouteurs cet égard
messi
merci d'avoir été là merci
[Applaudissements]
merci merci merci à tous les amis les
cherry on a une vidéo maintenant il ya
un certain xavier un certain xavier qui
nous envoyait une vidéo
xavier regarder sa vidéo je t'envoie
cette vidéo qu'elle voudrait faire
plaisir à mon ami et à nos enfants
effectivement elle a trois enfants et
moi étions 17 et pour tout ce beau petit
monde
on a juste un véhicule cinq places qui
entraîne nous lâcher quitte imagine bien
que pour les sorties
c'est mort alors voilà ce qu'on voudrait
nous c'est un véhicule 7 places ou neuf
places ça nul suffirait aux bleus m'en
allais te fais des bisous dernier taylor
on va plus après les sages avec xavier
on a vu matthieu delormeau en forme il
va être beaucoup moins en forme dans
quelques secondes
puisqu'il sera sur le toit d'une voiture
ce sera la cible et pour faire gagner la
voiture à xavier xavier devra lancer des
seaux de peinture sur la personne sur la
voiture sait pas encore si c'est des
sceaux autre chose
il sera à 25 mètres de haut en fait il
aura un panier de balles en mousse qui
devra lancer sur la voiture et il devra
viser la personne qui sera sûr de toi
normalement la personne qui sera sur le
toit non normalement cédric mathieu
delormeau ça peut changer incessamment
sous peu
mathieu il est là oui mathieu oui qu'est
ce qui se passe alors le temps que vous
arriviez on va vous laisser vous décidez
on se retrouve dans un instant
dans ce procès
merci d'être avec nous le shérif merci
d'être là on est ensemble pendant toute
la soirée et toute la nuit les chéris ça
fait exactement maintenant ah bah ouais
parce que son a dit marie a bien démarré
cette affaire à 14 heures il est 22h -
20 donc voilà donc ça fait vous faites
le calcul
et vous arrêtez le maire merci merci
d'être là on est en direct va se passer
encore plein de choses dans ces tournois
c'est cadeau il y à une personne qui
s'appelle xavier un qui nous a demandé
une grande voiture est ce que xavier et
dans le public qu'est ce que xavier on
l'a vu avec la perruque et xavier ce qui
peut descendre nous rejoint l'exode
[Applaudissements]
oui
merci lac d'allier
et merci d'être avec nous chez vous ce
soir ça va motiver
vraiment que ça venait ça va bien ça va
alors tu es content d'être là oui très
content je te sens pas comme un fou non
plus léché très bien c'est vrai j'ai eu
avec toute ma famille donc ça serait
alors vous êtes combien de la famille
alors on est douze en tout 12 1 famille
à tous les enfants là oui parce qu'en
fait racontant un peu toi tu étais moi
j'ai sept enfants ouais et ma nouvelle
compagne en a trois biens dont 4,7 +3
égale d'yssingeaux droit oui mais avec
nous ça fait douze avec tout ça fait 12
mois fais gaffe quand même nom mais je
te le dis et y en a un autre qui arrive
bien à notre cariven ces brigands sera
livré qu'en celui ci dans quatre mois et
demi quatre mois et demi
tu as pris coin tu as pris ta pris des
options il me parle de l'enfant dirait
qu'ils me parlent d'une nouvelle voiture
qu'il a d'après freinage abs et donc il
est affamé la wii est là et on a voulu
aider sans merci au revoir
on va les faire descendre toute la
famille mais pas tout de suite
vous aviez fait quoi dans la vie je suis
préparateurs de commandes donc je
prépare des commandes voilà où ça sur un
orgueil à côté d'amiens et dans quelle
société il y logistique iso logistique
donc c'était de la logistique facile
quoi pour ceux qui parlent un petit port
anglais bien entendu donc voilà donc à
des commandes car ils statuent les
préparer ensuite les gars arrivent et
prennent les commandes
d'accord ça te fait chier que je te
parle d'homophobie tous ces auteurs
voilà zabou nec monza biais mon xavier
chien je sais que c'est pas facile
d'acheter une voiture non mais c'est
vrai en plus
et toi c'est pas une voiture qui te faut
ça un minivan non mais sans rigoler
comment tu fais comment vous déplacer là
en fait maintenant
on se déplace pas je vais chercher les
enfants quand je vais chercher les
enfants
donc en fait en fait tu fais une sortie
par enfant quoi pratiquement un ami sort
pratiquement pas non c'est vrai ouais
donc on s'occupe autrement on fait quoi
on fait des petites vidéos wii et donc
tu m'envoies des vidéos enfin pour vous
voilà tsonga la télé oui beaucoup
regardent pas la télé déjà on regarde
votre émission sert merci merci xavier
sinon avec toute la famille les enfants
je les ai le week-end donc d'accord je
vais faire une émission le week-end
juste pour toi et tes ensemble parce que
cinq ans javier cette voiture j'ai très
envie de te la faire gagner
je ne peux pas te la donner parce que je
ne suis pas concessionnaires mais je
peux te la faire gagner
et tu va la gagner peut-être grâce à
matthieu delormeau tu aimes bien mathieu
delormeau
non je te comprends je te comprends
qu'est ce qui te gêne chez lui peu sûr
de lui mais des lieux depuis qu'il est
avec vous on fait ouais mais avant vous
n'aimez pas vous regardez pas vous ne
regardez pas
[Musique]
j ai dit ce qu'ils pensent et maintenant
ils aiment beaucoup mathieu mathieu ça
va vous nous entendez babin
malheureusement oui amer ah oui c'est du
jag et ça y est bien et xavier vous
allez rejoindre tout de suite mathieu
pour gagner la voiture c'est par là
allez-y regarder nos équipes nous
attendent
allez-y xavier alors pendant que xavier
aride
j'aimerais qu'on ait la liaison avec
matthieu delormeau mathieu est ce que tu
m'entends mme mathieu je suis là un
moqueur alors je suis la syrie cyril un
merci merci mathieu xavier va
s'installer à 20 mètres de haut
il y a une voiture 7 places à gagner
cette place pour vous ça veut dire de
trajet quand même marrant mais bon quand
même déjà ça mathieu vous allez être sur
le toit de la voiture est ce qu'on peut
voir le toit de la voiture avec la cible
regardez la cible donc la voilà regardez
regardez juste derrière vous voyez
mathieu mais je vois mais je vaux mais
non regardez ça arrive parce que le
réalisateur est un petit peu fatigué il
était en fait il est en train de filmer
sa mère donc voila merci
regardez il ya une cible et vous allez
être sur la cible mathieu voyou pas ah
oui j'ai vu la merci ben non harnaché à
la voiture pour faire gagner xavier qui
vous adore et en plus oui alors est ce
que je peux dire quelque chose oui bien
sûr voilà d'abord par rapport au fait
que j'aie l'émission à 18 heures le
vendredi je ne peux plus me permettre de
prendre des risques
et puis mon pied tout ça donc si ça vous
dérange pas comme je faire gagner xavier
j'ai une doublure cascade maintenant ah
oui je le montre winnie ils vous
ressemblent
winnie à la
avec elle il est beau il a eu une
augmentation il est content vous le
reconnaissez winnie montre toi à la wii
c'est votre assistant oui c'est mon
assistant voilà il est à brax donc oui
mais combien la prime de risque de
petites secondes
oui il a fait une petite couleur celui
ci non à ça vous a pas échappé à ces
deux pompiers m'ont m moi j'ai mis la
capuche parce que je prises et demain je
fais une couleur où ils entament pas ben
alors les chéris moi je veux pas savoir
qui va vous avez exactement 15 secondes
pour vous mettre d'accord
ouais alors eh ben c'est winnie c'était
bon tennis été augmentée c'est fait ils
savent écrire avant avant qu'ils
viennent faire de la télé et puis ça le
garçon n'était ne se nourrissent et que
deux mois il était fan ça se passait
très bien et maintenant vous les amis
des mauvaises idées dans la tête
voilà bon aouini winnie est ce que ça
vous fait peur un peu je voudrais juste
savoir combien et la prime de risque
alors ça c'est très pauvre avec matthieu
delormeau assez ça ça allait bien les
finances c'est mathieu merci voilà alors
c'est très simple je vous le dis on va
vous installer à la voiture est ce qu'on
peut installer donc on installe winnie
match aller où ils veulent aller winnie
d'accord là on installe winnie sur la
voiture les chiens ne le pousse et pas
on va installer winnie sur la voiture
est-ce que xavier est prêt est-ce que
xavier a le vertige est ce que sa femme
est ce que sa compagne peut descendre
est ce que pouvait descendre avec toute
la famille parce qu'on va voir papa voir
s'il va gagner à bhl
bon
[Musique]
ok merci j'attends alors j'embrasse tout
le monde va se retrouver dans une demi
heure
merci merci bonsoir madame bonsoir mon
soir à noizay bonsoir bonsoir ça lui
était passé tout à l'heure tu es venu
saluer toi je t'ai pas moi c'est comment
comment vous appelez coralie sa vague
idée sympa et xavier ouais ouais vous
avez vraiment besoin d'une voiture là je
sais pas comment vous faites nombreuses
mettez vous bien là alors tout cela
alors tout cela c'est c'est tout ça vous
roule alors en fait tout cela c'est à
mon mari d'accord et se lasser les miens
et en fait il y en a un prochain alors
là l'os c'est donc l'alliage voilà
d'accord quand mais c'est fou cette
l'animé mais comment fait à la maison
vous habitez dans s'éclate dans les
séries j'adore j'adore cette famille
alors xavier xavier est ce qu'il a le
vertige il avait généralement oui il a
le vertige et on a choisi la mauvaise
personne parce que xavier va monter
avant mètres du sol
il aura des petites balles en mousse
avec de la peinture un panier de balles
en mousse avec la peinture
[Applaudissements]
oui mais oui ça va oui ça va péter
winnie en tout cas cette position vous
met vraiment votre avantage mais vous
allez me vous avez une coque quelque
chose oui on l'a dit qu'il fallait
mettre une cote parce que je pouvais
voir madame les parties génitales
d'accord d'aqaba faites gaffe quand même
un oui d'accord et moi même ici j'ai le
vertige
non mais sans déconner alors oui mais
vous inquiétez pas xavier va devoir vous
visez avec des petites balles en mousse
avec de la peinture on veut s'ils
arrivent à vous toucher vous ferez
gagner la voiture à toute la famille
d'accord regardez la voiture allait
juste à côté elle est magnifique
oui ce serait bien ce serait bien pour
vous ça oui bah oui est ce qu'on est
prêt est ce que xavier près est-ce que
xavier précis pl ace combat
xavier san javier ça va aller répéter
arrête un set tourne c'est sympathique
ne prenez pas de risques
prenez pas de risques à xavier xavier
thouvenin ça va aller alors ce qu'on a
oublié de dire ça tourne oui c'est que
la voiture est mobile voilà puisqu'il ya
un cascadeur dans la voiture et dont
l'eau il va falloir viser
oui dit d'accord d'accord d'accord c'est
bon c'est bon vous êtes prêts oui vous
le sentez bien non vous allez devoir
toucher attention lundi en une minute il
va falloir touchés alors on en fait la
beauté
il va falloir touché cinq fois winnie
d'accord en une minute
ok attention c'est parti
non non mario asselin raylat à deux fois
deux fois trois fois quatre fois en zone
neutre et non seulement s camara plan
dont s'il vous plaît c'est plus
important
merci oui bah voilà un deux trois quatre
noms à côté il invoqua non c'est non et
nous en manque un faut vraiment qu'on
est là ils vont vraiment tourné la
marine seront sacrés
[Applaudissements]
c'est gagné
[Musique]
ça vient je
saleh mais la voiture et gazier mondial
bravache et la voiture c'est gagné j'ai
fait la voiture est à vous si vous
voulez aller voir et même si peut aller
voir papa allait pas parallèles voir
allaient devoir y aller
à javier a fait gagner la voiture
[Musique]
est ce qu'on peut avoir s'il vous plaît
est ce qu'on peut avoir des nouvelles de
mathieu delormeau et de winnie s'il vous
plaît oui oui la caméra on est là on est
là bravo mon mini fait très fier ah oui
vraiment oui parce qu'il a il a été bon
oui sachez que j'aurais aimé le faire si
j'avais pu bien sûr voilà bien sûr oui
ça va tu as ça va ça va là c'était
plutôt sympa
oui très c'est vrai oui il a une petite
douleur voiture selon les pays rigoler
comme vous rigolez mois dont vous
rigolerez mois dans un aspect enfilade
la marche qu'il soit vrai quoi vous
verrez vous avez peut-être faire gagner
un voyage à à quelqu'un qui m'aime
j'espère on va devoir dans un instant
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]